what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch Brooklyn
nine nine today season four episode ten
Captain Lut Veria joined of course bum
co-host John Humphrey
uh John I gotta leave a like they gotta
leave a like hey they should subscribe
and check out the patreon for full
length Reaction watch I should do that
you guys should do all that we should do
all of it do it according Cola do it do
it
really interesting
[Music]
thank you for joining me for what
promises to be the Diggity dopest tree
lighting in the history of the Nina oh
good timing to
the greatest inflate and flip tree that
America has to offer wacky inflatable
tree man
you hear that it's the sound of
Christmas it's deafening it's getting
really big what size tree did you get
it's a jumbo are you [ __ ] roughly 32.81
feet someone unplug it unplug it now we
can and swallowed his own plug Everybody
Run
laughs
The Blob okay the tree has been
contained wait we left a man behind
[Music]
Terry's trapped in the break room
forever only thing we can do now is move
on with our lives is what Terry would
have wanted
God bless us everyone
[Laughter]
that was pretty boss you should just put
the tree on the roof you can't just put
a tree on a roof or safety hazard you
need a permit
where are they going to get a permit hey
there nikolaj my man how you doing
got his name right
first Christmas because the
canceling
promised me the best present ever
Captain Lafayette action figure whoa I
said keep it a surprise so you don't
build up his expectations but Charles
said no way I want to build expectations
we all remember the conversation oh work
time for Daddy I'll see you guys later
try to get to Captain ordered it a month
ago from a Latvian Toy Story and it
still hasn't arrived yet the shipping
company is giving me the runaround all
right so just get him a different
present like a jet ski or a hammer I
don't know what kids are into guns lots
of guns Ah that's gonna be destroyed the
way dry rot destroyed his orphanage
trust me it's gonna be fine really you
said that about Die Hard five Jake oh
it's not gonna be fine
tired five is so bad does anyone have
any ideas about it
who are these annoying [ __ ] we're
here to wish you luck since every year
we kiss
our voices are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we're taking down the MTA
so
yo it's Christmas again and I'm here to
say
this jerk said they lost my package and
they said they found it then they had me
on hold for three hours this is the only
piece of a reliable reception I'm
unwrapping for a sec good call screen
let's just go there right now oh so they
could just walk over me in person
instead of on the phone we think about
all those moms who literally lift buses
off their kids every day oh so you're
saying I should tap into my mommy
strength yeah or daddy strength but
whatever right time to put some Daddy
into my mommy
[Laughter]
that was horrible because I didn't get a
chance to rap pop
pop dropping bodies it's a stick up here
[Laughter]
we're the nine nine and nothing can
stand in our way she's right we're gonna
beat their butts tonight tonight tonight
yeah I can I have Hamilton tickets oh
well good luck peace that is important I
mean if we're just gonna be humiliated I
don't wait shut up just tell yourself to
shut up yeah no you shut up too
you hear that there's an angel she
worked with Lim Manuel Miranda is that
Terry Crews who's singing is it one of
the uniformed officers no it is not
a prisoner oh him and our Angel is drunk
the angel puked you Melvin I am who are
you I'm Charles from being on hold
I already told you that package is in
here well I made a sacred promise to my
son and you're not gonna make a liar out
of me so why don't you take another look
we'll wait because we've got
all night
wow I'm a cop so maybe this time don't
lie to me hey I didn't know you guys
were police well no you do
there's a lot being gang okay the gals
skip who they smuggle guns and
containers that come from Latvia if you
want to find yours you got to find them
looks like we're gonna take down the
Latvia mob hell yeah we are
oh
the reason bleeding Charles is bleeding
[Laughter]
apparently the Gauss kapoo are major Gun
Runners on the East Coast their leaders
got an office in the back hey do you
think this shirt is offensive ah so
excited you're getting him Captain
Latvia and then there's a photo of him
karate chopping a cat oh yeah that's
Captain lafayette's move the Riga hammer
I got a joke for you what did one
Estonian farmer say to the other
our crop yields are so much smaller than
that of Mighty Latvia
[Music]
yeah the guy's a criminal
it was public intoxication all he did
was pee on a couple snowmen
and one regular man it's indecent
exposure too breaking rules makes you
all sweaty you can't be okay with this
these pits are bone dry the drunk sings
the drunk sing
wait Charles she doesn't speak any
English and we don't want to blow our
cover do you speak any Latvian well I
learned a few phrases for nikolaj don't
say You're Gonna use your musk I'm gonna
use my Musk
I mean this is the sexiest Boyle has
ever been I know Patrick solos Scully
mouth percussion Rose of mouth
percussion Amy silent mouth percussion I
can't even mouth percuss no Terry mouth
percussion Hitchcock
stay backstage you got it
from England Patrick sings us the
victory ladies and gentlemen but do you
have an opera singer on your hands yeah
dude
[Music]
oh he needs to be drunk sir say some
I'm sorry but there's been a police
emergency there's a bomb not here far
away but they still need us so Merry
Christmas and uh don't think about the
Box oh alcohol gives me the courage to
sing and the courage to pee on snow
people well well well
I found out that the only bomb out there
was you guys well it looks like the only
train in here is the train tell him Amy
reigning training wheels the circle and
find it find it Wheels you are wheels
nope
it's okay you tried fantastic dance
wow Boyle you got more moves than Bobby
Fisher who I saw a documentary about
last week
Jake follow me I figured we got 15
minutes before the pheromones wear off
and she realized I took the key or
Sprint him like a skunk out there yell
all that
I'm gonna broadcast what they did with
Captain Latvia they're not fools we
should go we've been here too long this
is getting dangerous well danger is my
maiden name
I gotta let my kid down not tonight
crap we've got company murder them I
found a tablet this could be something
hey thank God you're here do you think
this shirt is offensive
Hammer but that's not a real thing
[Music]
oh you want to do this in life the chop
custard
who's
be crazy how you took out that Latvia
mob guy back there I know I felt like a
superhero it's like the Hulk's mom
[Laughter]
five five five five damn it stop if you
keep getting it wrong we're gonna get
locked out forever that's a risk I have
to take
boom did it five six eight three fifth
most common passcode this year it spells
fart yep
[Laughter]
[Music]
sons of [ __ ] Turks just texted us a
gift of a cartoon subway train moving a
cop they sent it from the stage we
cannot let this stand but there's no way
we can beat them what do we do my
rapping's still on the table it's not
even in the dining room
I think we should go out there and just
sing our best caroling isn't about
competing it's about having fun together
well now that you put it that way Scott
it makes me realize Rosa and Terry are
right I say we quit the competition and
hurl projectiles at the MTN
baby miss not good enough to audibly
percuss who me I saved the flipping day
got Patrick drunk listen I can see
it's a bus pooping on a police car let's
beat those bastards he's gonna puke on
stage pee on the crowd after backup
arrives and not until then look I want
this to be a very special day for
nikolaj there's a gang of armed men in
there and we've done zero Recon I Won't
Let You Go in I mean it
all right we'll wait for backup
great job him that's the truck though
it's in that truck
stop scooching I am going scooch curse
my beautiful bubble butt see all four
men are blessed with a flat ass which is
perfect for scooching why are you acting
this way yep yeah I'm a boil deep down
the line you never will be hey yes I
will when Jake we're all waiting what
are we even arguing about now it's about
me saving Christmas duh now you have to
wait for backup no I don't I'm gonna
shimmy them off yes yes oh God the eye
contact is the worst part go Boyle I
told you Jake I'll do anything to perk
up my little man you've got to know how
gross that sounds in your underwear why
don't you just grab your pants
yeah put it back on
let everyone
eat my farts
oh no
just tell me what's going on so I know
where to send backup when it arrives ah
I'm north of loading Bay I have eyes on
the shipment there are only 10 guys only
that's too many guys they're removing
guns right they're taking the other
boxes no
Captain Mafia I have to go right now
it's too risky they have a ton of
weapons doesn't matter I'm going in
there and no one can stop me yeah
the Lafayette chop it works
I'm sorry I feel terrible for saving
your life enough your dumb apologies
Jake swat's here we have to move on
these guys now Charles you know what I
realized when I saw you standing over
there in your underwear now my butt is
like a sexy piece of drywall what no
whoa
now what I realized is the best gift you
can give new collage is not Captain
Latvia what it's you being there with
him alive but I promised him yeah but
you also promised him you were gonna be
his father I'm worried we're gonna lose
tactical back off Marv we get it come on
you guys look more upset than Aaron Burr
sir we lost the Caroling competition now
we hate singing almost as much as we
hate the MTA yes we should prank call
their tip line with a series of
well-crafted insults we should toilet
paper their houses
with rocks
I found him extremely melted and
grotesque probably should have strung
that together faster you taught me that
Christmas isn't about presents no forget
all that crap presence rule here give
him this from you it's a policeman just
like you papa
and I'm going to go to the farmer's
market I hope they have AIDS oh my God
I'm melting I aged gouda Genevieve hold
me I Got You Babe
I got you babe that flat ass is perched
right on top of my Ute I'm gonna pretend
none of that was said for the sake of
the child
hey guys I thought I'd spread the
Christmas cheer cool so you're just out
here caroling solo he's not solo okay
he's Cape damn right we did a one a two
a one two three down
got a really bad singers Papa yes they
are they're horrible
what is that song
I've heard it before it's an obscure
Latvian Christmas jingle
[Laughter]
damn that's one of my favorite crazy
Tunes there yes
it's quite quite crazy I don't know what
to say so you talk first ah it's a funny
episode I thought it was funny I enjoyed
the episode I I I
it's funny I did expect this to turn
into something that more directly
mirrored or parodied something like
jingle all the way but uh I did
appreciate the like I feel like the
Christmas episodes don't always feel
like Christmas is that important as
often times can be the case with
Christmas specials and things like that
not that this is even going out of its
way to be like it's special but I did
like the way that Christmas was like the
point of a lot of this and even like the
spirit of Christmas you both have to
learn in both plot lines have to learn a
valuable lesson about what truly matters
versus you know what you want and I
thought that was nicely handled and also
too you know what's cool about this
episode Scully my dude got a chance to
just kind of be a good character for a
minute there for you know he's I feel
like this episode both capitalized on
his natural abilities as a singer but
was also like hey
scully's got a pretty good grip on the
reason meaning of Christmas he's a good
Linus for this situation so I I'm always
happy to see Scully win once in a while
and then Hitchcock you know it'll happen
someday
yes I have more thoughts I would like to
to throw out there uh but also I know
yep I'm gonna say some more things yeah
are you okay is it Christmas
you coughing up some fake snow
it's like a deep breath of mountaineer
do you like caroling you like singing
Christmas carols you do
have you ever done it like in a group
for other people I have what was it like
oh baby baby how was I supposed to know
that's oh there wasn't right here
oh baby
that's beautiful
you cut that as a charity single for
Christmas
uh
no I've never done caroling I don't know
any Christmas songs okay not even not
even why there's one Christmas song I
think you do know the only one I might
know is
Mariah Carey yes
when actually her last name's Indian
it's Curry
red curry
Mariah Carey
all I want for Christmas is
you
I don't want to look for Christmas
um I also know John Lennon ooh
so this is Christmas
this is Christmas
and what have you done
you've wasted a whole year
being a bum
yeah man it's a Christmas
happy New Year
um yeah I know that but uh no this is
funny I like I like episodes where
things where they play against type you
know boils like a badass this episode
he's hilarious to others he's seductive
to that one chick lady woman female
thingy and he's um he's just a badass in
the field he's ready to go in there he's
smashing the cups yeah dude he took out
that one guard with his night stick I
did that at a Cheesecake Factory one
fresh the glass really wow what happened
well someone was attacking my woman
really so I crushed the glass and put
the glass in my hand and I smacked it
was just a big old Shard sticking on my
woman judging going you should have just
smashed the glass on the guys
yeah it's a much more direct you save a
step you know it's more efficient that
way yeah plus you might be able to jam
multiple shards
so yeah I've done that and uh
and uh what else happens caroling the
Caroling competition
it's kind of disjointed but it's like
buddy come here buddy Watson come here
buddy sing us a song Come here Watson
come here
I know buddy come here Watson
come here buddy do you come here what's
an old buddy now you're trying to learn
me to food but I can't right now
Watson where'd he go is he still there
is he gone did he leave did he take they
get on a train it's by the shoes now
okay he's going to the office down the
hall oh we should build a cat train here
dude build a cat train and then through
all the homes hit up rooms yeah and then
build four cars and then watches
you know as you struggle to force them
all to ride it and not immediately jump
off
um get that picture I think Christmas is
very much about competition and about
gifts I've seen it go down wrong when
you don't get gifts for people
that's a real Hazard like I don't
actually I don't expect gifts from
people
John's always like where's my Christmas
present correct
but you owe me every uh March or April
John's like got your present finally
came late yes I feel like I gave you a
marginally timely Christmas present last
year whatever that might have been was
that present I'm not sure
okay look I promise you get further and
further into life and you're like I
should start cataloging all the gifts I
give to people that way I can be
offended if they gift them forward
do you want this Captain America chair
no one really uses it I would love it
good thank you you want the Spider-Man
chair I know you don't like it very much
but I don't like this
but I do still support we're not working
with them
I mean you know the price for acquiring
these chairs was that they appear on
camera which they have so many times I'm
sure boys I think they're paid our dudes
we're good it looks so cool I know
they're not comfortable but I'm the only
one who complains about it not being
comfortable uh this one's more
comfortable than that one but you know I
think they're both very uncomfortable
chairs dude I you should get out there
and make your voice heard I'm right
several three star reviews
I know
but guys we want to announce we're
working with established titles yes do
you want to be a Lord with an asterisk
do you want a small piece of land you
could go visit the land you get will be
like five feet away from me or something
like that wherever whatever people say
we could all travel to Scotland and
stand on our plots and look at each
other yeah and go huh is that cool this
thing will be worth a fortune in 500
years
if the planet is still around by that
time you bet your ass
established titles
um and also name a star after someone I
think we talked about everything we need
to talk about Boyle's a good dad it's
kind of a disjointed episode a little
bit something about it didn't quite flow
with the MTA stuff I don't know I didn't
really give a [ __ ] to like go all out
here and criticize it it was fun it was
a fun Christmas episode what more do you
want or something really criticizing fun
boil being the star of it Terry Crews
was kind of here
Santiago being put down a lot and
obviously almost saved the day I know I
mean that was stupid idea to get the guy
drunk
yeah
but what were they gonna do the only
time you get a guy drunk is if he's
secretly a drunken boxer oh then you
should always get them drunk I know I'm
living
fact
the very next weekend
that would be good I would love to see
you in a drunken boxing fight
oh no I had a drunken boxer oh I was not
the drunk you got them drunk
fight I try to have sex with him because
I'm a drunken boxer this is just a drunk
anyway I think I've done my duty uh yeah
that was very romantic
oh damn fugitive part one and part two
it's a double episode that aired on New
Year's Eve we are on thematic track dude
and then
episode 12 then air tilt April
what yeah there's something wrong here
it must be who airs episode on the 31st
and why would there be such a big gap
when did the thumbnails run out
yeah that does seem strange unless they
had some kind of big
mid-season Hiatus when did Brooklyn nine
nine
season we're around four yeah episode
12 12.
air
January 1st that's even weirder
uh that's not weirder but it's also it's
weird also weird though what day of the
week was it
what is this like a two-night event
oh wait no but are they counting 11 and
12 yeah okay 11 and 12 or so it would be
13. right right okay
April okay I guess there was a big ass
Gap mid-season I guess so we won't we
don't have to continue until April yeah
we could take four months off yeah yeah
yeah and then when there's a real low we
really need some content then we'll come
back
um all right guys well that's weird
that's so odd yeah that happened I don't
know yeah there's an extended break
because yeah I was gonna say like there
is like I remember when my when my dad
was working on TV there would be like a
holiday break and yeah like you might
not air new episodes for a few weeks but
I don't remember it being like four
months later look who showed up on
camera hey buddy oh what do you got to
say he wants food okay we gotta do the
shout out all right so I'll feed him
guys we're gonna shout someone out
Ricardo Martinez Ricardo I just wanted
to say that if you're interested in
getting uh a plot of land in Scotland
and listen if you wanted it to be at
least a little bit next to me too and me
and John as well it would uh you got to
get an established titles uh there's a
code and someone another YouTuber's
subscription box that you could use and
by using that code
um you actually won't get what you're
looking for unfortunately because
established titles is apparently a scam
um it's just not as it appears that's
okay because neither are you Ricardo but
we've worked with them once before but
they didn't really want to work with us
again because the view count on that
video didn't quite live up to what they
wanted because to the authenticity of
their operations
and so I was like that's fine
but Ricardo listen buddy if there was a
chance that
if if when I die if I could have you
bury next to me oh I would feel better
about that dude because you're a latino
man and a latino man in the afterlife
would protect me and I believe that I
need a good Latino friend out there
watching my back because my white
friends are a bunch of punk ass [ __ ]
we can't communicate to Jesus for you
cowardly not afraid of conflict
especially with the top brass the only
tough people I know are the Latinos in
my life so I would like I would like um
I would like you to protect protect me
out there please that would mean a lot
Ricardo
if you can just teach me to be like you
you know I I want you to know Ricardo
that
I fantasize about us buying together
let's go home so if you wanted to get a
die at the same time as a bear a
cemeterial burial spot next to me go get
established title bar that's a bar I was
also just like a bonus gift yeah I'm
gonna use our promo code the established
titles is the death version of
established titles established
titles.com to get a death site uh you
and I buddy we're gonna do this together
we're gonna live next to each other for
the rest of our lives
like wow like Coke
yeah there you go and then Ricardo can
help you get into the Afterlife that way
I can sneak you in I don't know what
happens you know
you spell it
they uh they yeah Coco that's great I
cried you can get the Coco guitar for
like 200 bucks
the one from the animated movie you can
get it yeah is it anime
it only works when you plug it into your
computer uh but yeah now Coco you know
they go the afterlife they they rescue
Coco's soul from from perishing forever
but a long way he learns a lot about
vitality and about the fact that his
hero is like a fraud and stuff
that could be you guys
thanks Ricardo
you showed me the movie Coco and I'll
never forget that
[Music]